bienvenue dans le débat sur france 24
l'offensive russe en ukraine a démarré
il ya un mois maintenant une date qui
coïncide avec un triple sommet à
bruxelles autant g7 et conseil européen
en présence du président américain joe
biden l'otan a annoncé renforcer sa
présence en bataillon dans quatre pays
de l'est bulgarie roumanie hongrie et
slovaquie
sur le terrain les combats continuent
dans les environs de kiev notamment à
irp in ear pin où nous irons avec
justement un reportage exclusif pour
france 24 de notre envoyé spécial cyril
payen où en sont d'ailleurs les combats
cyril payen qui est avec nous on lui
posera la question en face de vous
gauthier rybinski est avec nous re
bonsoir gauthier cyril bienvenus nous
avons également pour commenter votre
reportage qu'on va voir bien sûr en
direct dans quelques minutes par skype
de vannes guillaume de rouget bonsoir
enseignants chercheurs à l'uqo
l'université catholique de l'ouest vous
êtes spécialiste des questions de
défense européennes et transatlantiques
cyril vous rentrez je le disais tout
juste d'ukraine justement cette banlieue
dire pin's et 70000 habitants à 15 km du
centre c'est là bas que se concentrent
les combats de rue pourquoi et bien
goûter parce que c'est un des axes
stratégiques les plus importants pour
encercler pour fabriquer ce siège qu'on
attend ou qu'on n'attend pas d'ailleurs
du côté ukrainien mais qu'on espérait et
qu'on avait pensé dans l'état-major
moscovite enfin en russe et c'est un
siège important c'est une bouée vouliez
très bien c'est au nord-ouest à 15 km du
centre ville et c'est là qu'il ya
quelques jours les combats que nous
sommes partis étaient faisait rage il y
avait quelques corridors humanitaires
pour évacuer ses région éminemment
résidentiel ce que c'est le district de
butch à dire pin et de ce tome elle ce
sont des dizaines de milliers
d'habitants sont en fait les habitants
un peu comme la la banlieue de paris
sont les gens qui ne peuvent pas habiter
en centre-ville dont qui habitent des
grandes tours des quartiers résidentiels
et qui sont sous le feu des tanks russes
qu'elle est en crue ski qu'on nous
sommes partis il ya quelques jours et
bien contrôler 50% de la ville d'hier
pin par exemple est aujourd'hui un
redoublement depuis 48 heures de combat
de cette offensive par r
artillerie tanks des combats de rue
aussi et avec ce qu'on a ce hack ont
assisté ce qui est cassé saisissant
cette résistance farouche à de la
population quand nous y étions il y
avait 1500 résistante des forces
spéciales l'ukrainienne des soldats mais
également des volontaires beaucoup de
volontaires étrangers aussi il y en a de
plusieurs centaines à pied d'oeuvre
puisque s'il s'agit de protéger kiev la
capitale donc les combats font rage on
allait encore là et là la rumeur ou par
excès certains analystes parlent
d'encerclement des forces russes ou le
fait qu'ils soient repoussées je pense
qu'il faut être extrêmement prudent là
aussi on est dans une quête
d'informations mais les combats font
rage et tout le monde a bien compris que
c'était déterminant de contrôler hier
pin pour contrôler l'accès nord ouest de
la capitale la bataille dire pincar des
deux guerres en ukraine cyril payen
[Musique]
les souris tout le monde
ce qu'on dit simon
monsoreau
jodoin
papa mail toujours
ian kington
au léger
des chnaoua
[Musique]
amman
[Applaudissements]
tu as des nouvelles de chez toi en
russie que pense-t-il là bas de la
situation
on ne me croit pas c'est complètement
dingue à moscou mes amis me disent même
combien on te paie pour dire de tels
mensonges c'est comme si je les
suppliais pour demander de l'aide qu'il
me réponde arrêté blague
je le sais maintenant si j'ai à le faire
je n'hésiterai pas je prendrai les armes
c'est ici chez moi je protègerai ma
maison mes amis chez toi
et ton petit frère que devient-il tu
sais quelque chose non rien je sais
simplement qu'il était sous contrat dans
l'armée dans ma ville en russie après
quelques informations que j'ai pu
obtenir au pays son unité est parti au
front dès le début de l'offensive en
ukraine
je n'ai aucun contact avec lui je sais
qu'il est quelque part là en face
on va voir
tous les ukrainiens qui sont réfugiés en
france et à l'étranger ne vous inquiétez
pas nous allons gagner et vous pourrez
bientôt tous rentrés chez nous de mieux
[Musique]
si vous voulez vivre prérentrée cette
côte et ses côtés des
armées qui contrôlent
[Applaudissements]
tiens je te file saporta grenade c'est
bon ça va marcher oui c'est bon bonne
chance merci
[Musique]
allez on va flinguer ces [__] de
russes
on a déjà tué des russes tous les jours
combien ça fait quatorze jours que je
suis là
j'habite ici je suis d'ici là
bon maintenant c'est chaud attention ils
sont dans le parc juste dans la rue la
halle
est ici c'est chiant très dangereux
lie à leur checkpoint
prost n'a 200 m lui aussi voit les tanks
un nom
à ton petit peu à temps c'est pas une
bonne idée de quoi il faut y aller
lingue
[Musique]
ce qui n'est pas rien
et ça
mon client qui l'a tué
des soldats russes
calvin les russes ont commencé à
attaquer de l'autre côté du parc lalla
par le sud
6 bord il y avait plein de gens
les civils et
mais ils ont fait exprès de tirer sur
des signes avec les iphone ils tuent
tout le monde pour gdansk et mulhousiens
bienvenue en enfer
allez viens suis-moi
ça c'est de l'alcool tu vois et en
ukraine maintenant c'est interdit
sur montreux salle
l'eau
chef
tout va bien pour nous
nous ne sommes pas caché
il n'y a pas de point de retour on ne
lâchera rien fait notre pays
tous ces [__] d'envahisseurs russie
ils vont regretter d'être venu moi faire
de l'engrais avec leurs cadavres
[Musique]
de la nourriture nous ne manquons pas
pour l'instant le problème c'est
l'électricité et l'eau bien sûr donc
tout dépend de la suite
mais les russes ne sont pas loin oui
mais vous pensez que vous allez devoir
partir aussi vous avez un plan les yeux
non plein aucun plan
regardez nous avons des gens ici et ils
ont besoin de nous
mon pauvre chien est à la rue comme moi
je suis à la rue ils ont bombardé la
maison ont cherché à adorer
nous sommes en vie
mais je n'ai rien à manger pour lui
mon pauvre chien eu
[Musique]
donc
comme vous y regroupent de seize soldats
russes est arrivé
c'était des jeunes recrues de bouriatte
yeux
les gens ont demandé qu'est ce que
l'ukraine a fait à bord et à thiais
pourquoi nous envahissent et vous
pourquoi venez-vous nous massacrer nous
l'ukrainien il ne répondrait un rien
juste il aurait pété nous avons des
ordres nous devons obéir aux ordres
il ya des cadavres partout en passant
nous avons même dû cacher les yeux des
enfants pour qu'ils ne regardent pas que
des civils c'est effroyable
on vient de passer devant vingt cadavres
juste là dans la rue là bas
il y avait un mort tout près du pont
c'est pas possible
de pauvres gens qui étaient à vélo et
qu'ils tentaient de fuir c'est vrai j'ai
pas dit choqué
merci merci d'être là pour nous défendre
nous prions pour vous libérez nous des
envahisseurs
merci on va les envoyer en enfer mon
cher fils je prierai pour toi tous les
soirs tenez bon nouveau chéri sont comme
nos enfants
merci merci beaucoup que dieu vous garde
en vie et que vous soyez réunis avec vos
familles vous êtes le héros
merci
ne vous en faites pas novak rond nous
allons gagner
merci merci
non ça nous sommes en guerre et
quelqu'un m'a collé une pub sur le
pare-brise sadi étudiants étrangers
comment trouver un boulot à kiev
[Musique]
c'est la statue du grand résistant
bordas lequel on its qui ça fait deux
bords dan
[Musique]
qui êtes vous jouez avec un français
gloire à l'ukraine gloire aux héros
place vous posez les pieds aujourd'hui
est très importante c'est un endroit
sacré pour nous peuple slave
nous avons été au cours des temps appelé
rousse puis rutten
mais maintenant nous sommes ukrainien
achats se moquera nous sommes dues
craignent un depuis à peine plus d'une
centaine d'animaux
j'étudie notre religion notre foi
cette fois est extrêmement puissante est
centrale pour nous depuis la nuit des
temps et la conclusion est la suivante
si nous sommes d'ukrainiens c'est que
nous avons résisté ukraine signifie
résistance
[Musique]
au fond
ça partait ouais ça va ça va je suis
prêt je suis prêt pour la bagarre
allez ça va péter
et ils sont très proches dont
ces connards sont en train de pilonner
ils essaient de flinguer notre
artillerie on va leur répondre on va
aller réduire ensemble
à lillers oui savoir un homme qui en qui
[Musique]
ils ont défoncé le coin ou quoi
m
ping
[Musique]
six rites païens donc un qui a tourné ce
reportage cyril justement un mot
peut-être sur cet engagement des
ukrainiens cette résistance ukrainienne
qu'on voit finalement du côté de tous
ces ukrainiens qui sont différents les
uns des autres mais qui résiste aux
côtes route oui effectivement on a ce
jeune artiste qui lui fait de l'exode à
l'envers puisqu'il va vers kiev il y les
deux loutres dans le frontière de la
biélorussie et il veut résolument
retrouver sa résidence d'artistes et lui
ne prendra certainement pas les arbres
mais il sait ça mène à de résister donc
il a fait des performances où il danse
où les bombes il s'est mis en scène et
partir et il se brouille il restera de
toute façon il ya aussi la conscription
obligatoire qui fait que toute personne
mal entre 20 et 60 ans on ne peut pas
quitter le pays ont déjà c'est ça la
règle c'est la loi martiale mais vous
avez cette mobilisation saisissante qui
était certainement pas prévu à cette
échelle par moscou ça c'est évident mais
pour l'avoir vécu qui est saisissante
dans son ampleur dans son application on
voit ces personnes âgées qui disent nous
ne partirons pas et donc je ne sais plus
je peux pas d'ailleurs attesté qu'ils
sont encore vivants aujourd'hui
puisqu'il ya des combats féroces aaer
pin mais ce facteur de mobilisation
nationale quelle que soit la génération
quel que soit bien la profession où la
fonction de c2c sucré lien est quelque
chose d jacky pas rentrer dans l'est
dans les mémoires qui déjà historique
gauthier peut-être accents justement mis
dessus quelques ce que ce que dit aussi
rider capital c'est à dire quelle que
soit la profession la génération quelles
que soient les idées politiques et
quelle que soit la langue c'est à dire
que ce que nous venons de voir le lui le
documentaire de syrie pas il est capital
parce que la plupart des personnes que
vous interrogez dans la rue qui sont qui
sont des ddd jaillir des citoyens lambda
ce sont des gens qui s'exprime en russe
ce qui veut dire que la distinction est
nico linguistique que vladimir poutine
pratique dans sa théorie pour imposer
cette invasion en disant qu'il défend
les russophones elle si belle s'effondre
comme un château de cartes ce n'est pas
la première fois et le documentaire de
serre il le prouve encore mais chaque
soir nous présentons des images avec des
témoignages de personnes qui s'exprime
en russe alors il y en a bien sûr en
ukrainien mais ça ne veut rien dire si
vous voulez cette distinction cette
frontière qui prête qui sert de
fondement à l'action du poutinisme on va
dire parce qu'ils payent seuls à avoir
cette théorie raciale finalement eh bien
elle ne tient pas vous avez quantité de
russophones y compris à l'est du côté de
marioupol par exemple qui se sent
profondément ukrainien et ça ne les
empêche pas de parler le russe dernier
exemple vous souvenez peut-être du maire
de milito paul qui avait été détenu par
des soldats russes et quand il a été
libéré le président ukrainien volodimir
zelensky l'a appelé au téléphone en quoi
parle-t-il en russes en russe guillaume
de roger vous êtes le spécialiste
défense de ce plateau c'est justement
cette cette gnac ce patriotisme des
ukrainiens sur un terrain de combat ça
une vraie valeur face justement aux
forces russes
nous avons un problème de son toutes mes
excuses les ir vous pouvez entendre et à
l'isi merci oui c'est toute la question
donc du moral des troupes est derrière
du lien armée nation en réalité un
continuum s'est très rapidement
constitué entre la tête du gouvernement
et donc donc volodymyr zélande qui
incarne
l'héroïsme d'un gouvernement qui tient
qui cherche à rester sur place et à
partir en exil etc et qui influe un
esprit de résistance mais qui a
rencontré évidemment en écho par le bas
sinon il aurait bien sûr échoué dans sa
dans sa tâche quasi churchill yens et
évidemment on retrouve à travers à la
fois le flot des réfugiés vers l'ouest
mais également tous les hommes qui
restent ou qui reviennent et à travers
un certain nombre de figures les maires
vous avez vous avez cité un exemple
critiqué qui est très important on peut
aussi penser
vitali klitschko le frère aîné de cesser
ces deux boxeurs qui est le champion du
monde et donc qui est le maire qu'est le
maire de kiev et ya certes de figures
comme ça et les maires sont très
importants puisqu'il renvoie et là je
voulais simplement
notre faire une transition vers vers
l'opposé en fait vers vers vers les rues
c'est là le moral des russes et qu'il
renvoie aussi aux limites de la
stratégie russe les russes ont été
obligés de kidnapper un certain nombre
d'autorités politiques ou d'essayer de
les mettre sur la touche dans des dans
les cités qui en réalité n'accueillait
pas les forces russes comme le les
renseignements sans doute on commence à
le penser très sérieusement un fossé ou
qui n'étaient pas parvenus à vladimir
poutine eh bien le
démentaient c'est à dire qu'il n'y
aurait pas un accueil très favorable
dans autant de régions dans autant de
zones que les russes l'espérait et ça
renvoie derrière aussi eh bien à cette
asymétrie dans la question de moral des
troupes à la russie qui a de gros
problèmes manifestement de de morale et
là on voit que il ya un problème de
commandement il ya un problème de
ressources humaines on va appeler des
des forces qui n'ont pas vraiment de
rapport avec le patriotisme russe en
lui-même et qui ne savent pas vraiment
où elle où elle dans quelle région elle
arrive et puis il ya aussi des troupes
qui se pose vraiment manifestement des
questions quant à la légitimité au bien
fondé de la guerre aux finalités
stratégique donc on voit effectivement
ce ce différentiel cela dit si je peux
me permettre de le démettre c'est une
nuance qui nous plongera dans l'autre
partie du débat militaire c'est que le
moral ne fait pas tout et que parfois on
peut être malheureusement prise en otage
par son propre héroïsme cyril est ce que
justement ces combattants c'est
l'ukrainien vous avez rencontrées vous
parle de l'armement occidentale de la
nécessité justement il ya eu un sommet
de l'otan aujourd'hui qui a confirmé
aussi une aide américaine il y à une
aide européenne on sait donc sur du
matériel défensif est ce qui vous en
parle sur le terrain on le voit donc
c'est ça aussi c'est difficile à enfin
c'est un fait on a vu arriver au passé
environ une semaine à irbine est arrivé
de plus en plus de matériel on voit sur
le dans le film d'ailleurs des snipers
donc des éléments des forces spéciales
l'ukrainienne où des soldats du rang
mais qui ont des armes beaucoup trop
neuve pour qu'elle soit issue de leur
propre armement donc ça c'est de l'art
de l'armement occidental est arrivé oui
qui t'arrive vient d'arriver et feront
certainement bien sûr qu'ils en parlent
l'eau qui parvient à bon port si je puis
dire absolument et puis même d'ailleurs
plus que des armes enfin des canons des
drones que parce qu'ils utilisent
beaucoup de drones en ce moment des
drones armés qui font beaucoup de mal
d'ailleurs à l'armée russe donc oui
c'est même pas un secret et c'est
participe aussi de ce2 de cet élan est
de faire passer le message qu'on fait
partie d'un geste global même même si il
regrette et comme le président aux
hellènes ski qu'on avait pu rencontrer
ya une dizaine de jours regretté que
l'application et on en parle
certainement en ce moment soit pas plus
importante qu'on ne considère pas en
fait c'est l'europe qui est attaqué
c'est le continent européen qui est
attaqué par vladimir poutine mais il ya
cette cette mission sacrificielle qui
est très bien illustré est porté par le
président zelensky et qui montre comme
ces combattants sa part de vulnérabilité
donc ce n'est pas de gaulle c'est autre
chose c'est un homme qui qui montre sa
faiblesse qui nous a montré ces
sentiments a passé environ deux heures
avec lui et et il représente
parfaitement son peuple c'est pour ça
que ça marche bien en communication
parce que il ira jusqu'au bout et on
voit tous ces hommes des femmes on voit
bien que ceux avec qui j'ai passé du
temps ne partiront pas ne capitulons pas
c'est certain on va l'écouter justement
vladimir
ce ne sont pas vos missiles ce ne sont
pas vos bombes qui détruisent nos villes
ce matin d'ailleurs il y avait des
bombes au phosphore et bombe russe au
phosphore des adultes ont encore été
tués et des enfants encore été tués je
veux juste que vous sachiez l'alliance
peut encore empêcher la mort
d'ukrainiens à cause des frappes russe
de l'occupation russe en nous donnant
toutes les armes dont nous avons besoin
surtout ce brouille au moteur mme
gauthier alors le président ukrainien
évoque d'utilisation de ces bombes au
phosphore il n'a pas pu le vérifier en
tout cas pour pour l'instant eyene
riposte occidental qui est même assez
forte elle est symbolisée par joe biden
à bruxelles lors de ce sommet de l'otan
et de ce sommet l'union européenne est
elle suffisante cette riposte pas
suffisante pour un client tient mais si
vous voulez aller elle est paradoxal
cette riposte parce que l'attitude du
président des états unis et d'autres
chefs d'état européens consista à bander
les muscles à dire nous sommes là et
nous soutenons très bien sauf que à
chaque fois nous soutenons quoi on pose
des lignes rouges implicite et on les
reculs à chaque fois que moscou avance
c'est là le problème c'est que l'image
qui est donnée à moscou c'est l'image
d'un occident effrayer
évidemment nous sommes mais d'un
occident et free et qui prêt à reculer
et qui est prêt même à dire il faut
laisser des portes de sortie à vladimir
poutine c'est à des confrères de la
presse française n'hésite pas à créer ce
genre de choses parce que nous sommes
aussi dans cette culture de la paix il
fait que nous n'avons pas la conscience
et les ukrainiens dont parle série dans
son documentaire ont eu cette conscience
de impérative impérieuse de ce qu'est
être européen et nous qui sommes
habitués depuis 77 ans à la paix nous ne
voyons pas de prétexte pour nous engager
plus si nous nous engageons pas pour
cela pourquoi on s'engagerait d'autres
c'est ça la question et la question
n'est pas de trouver un échappatoire à
vladimir poutine parce que si on lui
trouve un échappatoire on règlera
l'ukraine avec en amputant l'ukraine
deux régions où x oblast et pour le
reste on aura un vladimir poutine
intacte qui m'a crime akira cela en
victoires et qui se portera sur un autre
endroit sur une autre sur un autre pays
ultérieurement guillaume derechef
d'accord avec ce que vient de dire
gauthier gauthier rybinski et puis une
question aussi sur les s-300 parce que
si j'ai bien compris il ya un débat sur
un envoi de ses systèmes de défense
antiaériens de slovaquie entre les
américains et les slovaques
ah oui alors pardon les s-300 ça serait
ça serait qu'un élément su bien
simplement pour réagir aux propos de
de gauthier vous voyez dans un sens il
ya cet appel oui à des valeurs à des
valeurs fondamentales de l'europe et
même plus généralement d'ailleurs de
quelque chose qui relève aussi de la
marche du monde vert et bien une
compétition qui en réalité serait
circonscrite des domaines économiques
sociaux culturels bref qui mettrait la
guerre hors la loi en réalité on est
quand même dans une situation ne
l'oublié pas où nous avons une puissance
nucléaire et pas n'importe laquelle
l'une des deux principales puissances
nucléaires historique et d'ailleurs si
l'on en croit les chiffres celle qui
détient le plus de l'ogive nucléaire
alors évidemment la question de laisser
une porte de sortie à vladimir poutine
dans ce cadre là elle a quand même une
certaine légitimité et elle a même une
certaine rationalité et je pense même
que il faut absolument maintenir ce fer
au feu ce n'est pas le seul évidemment
mais si l'on comprend tous est en jeu
aujourd'hui comme celui d'une
détermination qui va falloir maintenir
dans le temps évidemment c'est une
détermination économique et une
élimination aussi culturel qui porte
certain nombre de valeurs de liberté et
c'est de paix mais bien sûr derrière les
mots il ya des réalités il ya une
détermination dans la dissuasion
nucléaire et ça c'est d'abord le rôle
des trois puissances nucléaires france
le royaume uni etats unis depuis 2014 on
l'a rappelé un l'alliance menace
nucléaire mais aussi chacun de nous est
un pays nucléaire il vous aura pas
échappé que nous avons des exercices
nucléaire ou le faisons savoir mais
est-ce que fonctionne aujourd'hui cette
dissuasion nucléaire parce qu'en fait
les lignes rouges manifestement quelles
sont-elles lorsque joe biden dit qu'il
n'interviendra pas s'il ya par exemple
effectivement une intervention si la cie
l'ukraine est envahi les américains
n'interviennent pas si effectivement il
y avait une attire en pologne par
exemple est-ce qu effectivement les
américains interviendrait on peut pas on
peut pas partir d'une hypothèse dirait
générique d'un tir sur un pays de l'otan
ça dépend de tout un contexte ça
dépendrait d'un contexte est-ce que
c'est accidentel est ce que ça ne l'est
pas qu'est-ce que ça vise quelle est la
nature de ce tir etc d'accord
l'essentiel c'est de comprendre que la
dissuasion c'est un dispositif technique
une bombe nucléaire mais aussi un
dispositif politique et rhétorique je
peux avoir une bombe nucléaire et ne pas
savoir dissuader tout simplement pas en
fait je suis fou et que je cherche à
l'utiliser ou je n'ai rien à perdre et
sans être fou se dissuasion du faible au
fort il faut que je cherche à l'utiliser
la dissuasion c'est quelque chose qui
correspond à une arme soit de non emploi
soit d'emploi quotidien en réalité si on
prend en compte l'idée que ça s'inscrit
dans un certain nombre de gestes qui
considère qu'il ya une proportionnalité
qui considère qu'il ya une forme de
crédibilité d'un leadership de
crédibilité d'un gouvernement qui
considère que également il ya une forme
de parité des vulnérabilités c'est à
dire que le fondement de la dissuasion
un enfant de 4 ans peut le comprendre
céline et que je ne vais pas agir parce
que les coûts de mon action serait
risque d'être supérieur au gain mais
bien sûr vous avez des cerfs des
rationalités qui peuvent sortir de ce
cadre et vous avez également des formes
d'irrationalité par un problème
d'information un problème de mauvais
calculs un problème de mauvaise
communication
souvenez-vous en le téléphone rouge
après la crise du cuba donc on est dans
une situation évidemment la dissuasion
nucléaire n'est pas seul il faut bien
comprendre si vous voulez c'est juste
impossible une seconde que derrière
c'est aussi tout l'enjeu du sommet de
l'otan aujourd'hui d'avoir décidé
d'amener davantage de force des gens
faisaient depuis 2014 sur le flanc s des
forces conventionnelles c'est aussi le
rôle de tout ce qui concerne le saut
conventionnelle c'est à dire la lutte
contre la désinformation russe le
soutien aux renseignements des
ukrainiens et puis bien sûr lèvres aux
ukrainiens dont on a commencé à parler
ça parle est un jeu c'est tout un jeu de
reprendre l'ascendant et là où je
voulais dire que j'étais tout à fait
d'accord avec gauthier c'est qu'on a
effectivement un sentiment d'effroi
depuis le début et que de ce point de
vue là l'agitation eurus et la menace de
la deûle usage de toutes les forces à
disposition a effectivement joué sur les
populations j'en vois chez les personnes
qui ont connu la guerre froide on le
voit chez les personnes plus jeunes les
balkans dans les années 90 ont été un
révélateur avec finalement au moment où
l'union européenne mais des formes de
crimes contre l'humanité à nos portes
mais on était dans une sorte de déni ou
de distance pour la bonne et simple
raison qu'on ne se sentait pas
directement concerné ça ne pouvait pas
se passer chez nous aujourd'hui on voit
que oui fondamentalement la russie est
tellement agressif que ça peut se passer
potentiellement chez nous et la russie
en joue donc c'est effectivement
retrouvé un ascendant dans cette crise
qui est très sympa c'est je le dis ce
n'est pas seulement l'oeuvre des
militaires ce n'est pas seulement
l'oeuvre de longtemps c'est l'oeuvre de
toute une communauté internationale et
d'énormément de ressources et pour
longtemps cyril sur le terrain est ce
qu'on vous dit ça va durer plusieurs
mois ça va durer longtemps dans préféré
ne pas le dire mais c'est une évidence
évidemment toutes les siens pas d'espoir
sur le terrain que ça s'arrête là pour
le moment on est dans une résistance on
a vu ce combat de rue ça peut durer des
mois certainement enfin en tout cas les
combattants se sont résolues à rester le
temps qu'il faudra et ça sera très très
bon évidemment mais c'est ce qu'ils
anticipent eux la durée absolument oui
absolument c'est ceux qui sont là sont
là pour rester la guerre justement elle
profite à qui lorsqu'elle dur là et bien
c'est là aussi c'est le temps long qui
va profiter ou pas et c'est pour ça
qu'il ne faudrait pas aller trop vite
parce qu'on parle beaucoup de cette
cette zone du nord ouest de la capitale
où il ya eu des combats on parle
d'encerclement par le même
certains observateurs parlent d'un d'un
début de retrait russe ou clé russe
reculerait là aussi je pense qu'on va un
peu vite parce que je ne pense pas
nécessairement que les russes aient tous
déployés face et à la pression sur place
tous déployés de leur force de frappe à
ce moment là dans ces zones là et est ce
que le temps là le haut quand on a vu le
président est né ce qu'ils
les russes sont en train de
je pense pas je pense qu'on est dans une
guerre informationnelle et chacun
véhicule sa propagande des c'est tout à
fait compréhensible du côté ukrainien
mais on n'est pas dans les bons chiffres
nécessairement et puis de dire que les
forces russes sur recul je ne pense pas
que les ukrainiens aujourd'hui des
forces ukrainienne donc celle qu'on voit
dans le film soit en capacité de faire
reculer de manière substantielle les
forces russes maintenant sur le temps on
voyait le président dave qui a dix jours
on lui dit vous êtes vous êtes fatigué
l'ukraine est fatigué donc tout cette
mobilisation aussi nationale qui est
incroyable dans sa pensée dans sa mesure
dans son ensemble est ce que avec le
temps ça va aussi dure et c'est
compliqué et c'est peut-être là que du
côté russe on s'apprête à prendre ce
temps et à s'installer sur des bases
c'est-à-dire en fait sur les chiffres on
en fait et puis bien que le temps ce
jour en faveur de l'offensive russe
reste à savoir relégation les options
diplomatiques alors quel scénario pour
les prochains jours bon les options
diplomatiques c'est compliqué parce
qu'on va voir un certain nombre
justement de rencontres diplomatiques
est-ce qu'on va vers une aggravation des
sanctions oui probablement est-ce
qu'elles vont être efficace on ne sait
pas on n'a pas encore non plus le recul
nécessaire pour voir ce que les
précédentes sont sanctions ont opéré sur
le caractère russe mais
fondamentalement il je reviens je fais
lier la liaison entre votre question est
ce que disait guillaume de rouge et tout
à l'heure la question de ces valeurs
européennes ce n'est pas pardonné mois
guillaume ce n'est pas que une question
de bon ou de jolis mots je donne un
exemple très pratique précisément c'est
par le mépris de ses valeurs de liberté
d'expression libre que vladimir poutine
maintient aussi son peuple en situation
de le soutenir et en situation donc de
se préserver lui-même d' une
contre-réaction que sa population
pourrait un jour peut-être produire ça
veut dire aussi que grâce à
l'embrigadement au fait que les masses
rue soit enrégimentés c'est ce qui
permet à cette guerre de durée je ne dis
pas que c'est la seule chose bien sûr il
ya d'autres facteurs mais ce facteur
existe aussi donc les fameux bons mots
dont on parlait tout à l'heure ils sont
aussi capitaux de manière presque
tactique et plus vladimir poutine aura
le soutien de son peuple plus il pourra
poursuivre c'est une réalité au sein
diplomatique du coup les efforts
diplomatiques se voulait c est ça le
moment il ya six parce qu'il faut
toujours effective ce qu'ils
abandonnaient plus ou moins liés
d'entrer dans l'otan on a vu aussi qu'il
y à un certain nombre de retraits en fin
de reculade de la part des russes vous
avez vu au départ c'était la
dénazification de l'ukraine maintenant
on en revient à parler de territoires de
neutralisation de l'ukraine de
récupération du donbass ou de
négociation tout ça est opportuniste est
ce que c'est un signe que l'armée russe
et dans la délicatesse oui ça ne veut
pas dire que le disait cyril calé dans
vraiment en retrait ou en ou en
débandade mais ça veut dire que l'armée
s'adapte là ou plutôt le pouvoir
s'adapte à la situation de l'armée ce
qui n'avait pas été le cas et le
problème de poutine s'est aussi
manifestement ses services de
renseignement l'ont trompé trop zélé à
vouloir lui faire plaisir guillaume
roujas ya des options diplomatiques sur
la table aujourd'hui où c'est trop tôt
pour en parler vous pensez égal que la
guerre sera longue et que si elle est
longue elle risque de profiter plutôt
aux russes ça fait beaucoup de questions
en très peu de temps mais
fondamentalement à la première question
les solutions diplomatiques pour
l'instant ce qu'on voit c'est qu'elles
sont en réalité très tributaire de ce
qui se passe sur le terrain on a vu le
secrétaire général de l'otan aujourd'hui
on appris à la chine ce qui en soi est
problématique puisque on voit bien que
l'otan la tendance à essayer de d'entrer
dans un jeu plus vaste que ce qui est
d'abord sa zone euro atlantique et ce
qui est aussi fondamentalement un rôle
militaire alors qu'on voit que pour la
chine on rentre là dans un jeu beaucoup
plus général de détermination d'une
communauté internationale pour faire
plier vladimir poutine mais jusqu'à ce
que ce que je veux dire par là c'est
qu'effectivement il ya des grands jalons
la chine la turquie la position de
l'inde un autre position bien sûr
fondamentalement ces états unis etc on
voit que en revanche pour l'instant
c'est davantage qui se passe sur le
terrain qui va dicter la donne c'est à
dire que l'on risque effectivement
d'avoir une guerre d'usure maintenant
reste à voir si on arrivera à une table
des négociations lorsque les deux
parties seront totalement arriver à un
état d'épuisement comme ça a été plus ou
moins le cas dans les balkans ou si il
va y avoir une escalade soit horizontale
c'est à dire d'autres théâtres qui vont
être touchés soit verticale c'est à dire
une escalade qui va encore dépasser les
seuils de violence et de brutalisation
que l'on connaît depuis maintenant un
mois cyril guerre d'usure c'est le terme
qui a utilisé un guillaume de rogers l'a
beaucoup entendu aujourd'hui on
al'impression effectivement qu'on est
que ça bascule est aujourd'hui vers
cette guerre d'usure bah oui parce que
c'était une guerre éclair qui avait été
pensé par l'état major et les services
de renseignement russes avec
l'établissement d'un gouvernement lâche
hull à la chute du gouvernement a
accueilli tout cela était prévu pour ne
pas durer et aujourd'hui ben ça fait un
mois et on peut penser qu'il y en aura
d'autres maintenant des mois en tout cas
c'est toutes les positions russes
notamment pour ne parler que de cette
périphérie de dire pin ils sont là pour
rester et que ici le recul de 10 km
toute façon ils réagiraient avant seront
donc tout le monde se prépare sur le
terrain j'ai pu avoir d'ailleurs deux
des protagonistes du film juste avant
l'émission ici les combats font rage il
résiste et ça va durer de toute façon
ils le savent c'est totalement inscrit
dans leur calendrier il ya combien dire
pin justement en ukraine aujourd'hui
vous parliez de 6 ans c'est la bonne
question de la bonne question les russes
ont attaqué on le sait sur plusieurs
fronts il se concentre sur certaines
villes dont ils ont finalement pas une
convention dont je pense à mario paul
qui va être qui est déjà tellement de
dossiers être carrément de cicatrices de
guerre qui est fait un autre problème
puisque c'est quand même le symbole que
recherchent à conquérir vladimir poutine
c'est le symbole de la de la deûle et de
l'âme slave donc on va pas raser ce sera
pas un alep ça sera pas à grozny kiffe
mais par contre en cercle et étouffer
oui c'est ce qui se passe c'est pour ça
que le temps long et la guerre d'usure
l'épuisement notamment des forces
ukrainienne c'est certainement dans
l'adaptation de la stratégie de moscou
dire qu'en fait il y a deux cent mille
hommes sur le terrain qui enserre qui
épuise et ça va durer effectivement
longtemps mais il n'y aura pas de
bombardements du centre de kiev ça
paraît un non sens puisque l'idée était
de faire capituler kiev en l'état de
mettre un gouvernement fantoche et
d'affirmer la possession russe sur 7 sur
7 capital cotise guerre d'usure comme
sarajevo par exemple on peut faire des
parallèles coûté oui cette guerre
d'usure c'est comme elle est comme nous
vient de la décrire cyril il faut voir
ce qui peut être fait pendant ce temps
là est ce que est ce que cela sert les
ukrainiens oui dans la mesure où ça peut
leur permettre d'être vraiment là la
panique des soldats russes qui s'ils
sont immobiles sont beaucoup plus
vulnérables donc panique parce que parce
que les ukrainiens son mobile parce
qu'ils reçoivent des missiles adapté à
la lutte antichar donc là ça peut être
quelque chose de bénéfique pour eux mais
on sait aussi ce que disait cyril payen
tout à l'heure les russes ont encore des
réserves d'hommes est considérable qui
ne sont pas encore rentrés manifestement
qui ne sont pas encore entrés dans le
combat dans la lutte et donc ses
réserves la peuvent être amené à
suppléer ceux qui sont moralement et
même physiquement exténué parce que
certains noms n'ont pas de nouvelles de
leurs proches parce qu'ils sont coupés
d'un commandement parce que certains
n'ont même plus à manger et c'est donc
là ça peut ça peut jouer maintenant que
se passe-t-il pendant qu'on fait une
guerre d'usure est ce que la diplomatie
marche ce qu'on vient de nous dire ce
que dit guillaume de rouget et syrie est
tout à fait juste ça s'adapte aussi aux
terrains et c'est le terrain qui va
dicter et quand le terrain ne bouge pas
ou pas beaucoup que fait la diplomatie
franchement là j'ai pas la réponse à
cette patine en tout cas elle un peu
merci beaucoup à tous les trois merci
guillaume nadeau rouge est d'avoir été
avec nous enseignants chercheurs à lui
merci à tous et puis bien sûr si cyril
cyril payen denquin ce reportage
documentaire qu'on peut retrouver encore
sur france 24
www.francebillet.com sur le site
internet merci gauthier l'émission vous
pouvez la retrouver aussi en podcast
podcast débat merci à tous d'avoir suivi
reste avec nous
tél